you I L you please Len
me I know her but who
she where's she
at Mark I'm going to go talk to her
okay just talk to me okay okay okay stay
over here what's going
on I actually don't know but I got hit
in the face so I swung back Kel hit you
in the face I yeah okay right here okay
I'm going to get a picture of your face
okay cuz we're going to need it all
right
okay so what happened how did this start
first I was playing pool I work here
okay are you working tonight or just you
work right now no my mom just saw we're
just hanging out playing pool
and some stupid came up about her and
somebody else and I was actually trying
to diffuse the
situation and boom I get hit so I swung
back so how did I'm I'm it's just a
little unclear did K was Kelsey talking
shit about someone or yes who is she
talking shit about you know what I
couldn't even tell you that's what Su I
couldn't even tell you who she was
talking about but I work here and we
don't so you just Tred to go calm her
down and
she
[Music]
okay she clocked her pretty good no look
at look at Hur pretty good she's
bleeding no look at look at look at the
video look at the video she wants what
look look at the video look at the video
Don't Get Loud with me oh shut
up I know this motherfucker look at the
video okay don't get loud with me yeah
I'll be loud cuz you're fake what do you
meany stop tell this little punk cuz you
have the authority I never hit
[Music]
her well yeah cuz he knows he cares
about me he knows he knows it hit her so
go on me dude you know Cal you need to
calm down well don't talk to me that's
my best friend I just came out here
saying that is my best friend hey Kelsey
hey Kelsey come over here I got
basically beat
down in the Kelsey
Kelsey kelse hey Kelsey I didn't come
you don't even know yeah I do know you
actually no but you don't know what
happened okay I know I'm not I didn't
come out here I didn't did I come out
here saying hey arrest her now you're
like you're like oh you I'm hey Kelsey
talk to me like I'm a normal person okay
Kel can we can we talk like we're normal
people I didn't do anything I didn't hit
anybody I didn't do anything okay did
[Music]
I did I I don't I don't know yet Kelsey
I'm trying to I'm trying to get a story
straight but I please that's why going
out like public I can't get a story
straight when you're screaming at me and
in my face okay oh my God nobody's
screaming at you it's cuz you're like
trying to manh me I'm that's that's when
I say if I was trying to manhandle would
have been a
problem you need to talk to me like I'm
a human being yeah same with you and
that's why I I did I want I'm coming out
here trying to get a story Kelsey I
didn't come out here I didn't come out
here and just start I know my dude in
there is my friend officer I didn't
touch anybody okay I'm trying to get a
why am I going to get arrested I didn't
did it who said you were getting who
said you were getting
arrested no one
arrested put your shirt on girl are you
do Did anyone say you were getting
arrested right now up did anyone get
arrested
really yes I'm going to say it why why
why you your judgment about me I know I
haven't Kelsey I'm you're like well you
do this in this no I didn't
listen all right she wants to get
arrested so wait for punching her okay
who punched anybody your back no I'm not
I'm getting arrested no
reason I'm getting arrested for no Reon
I'm not I'm not I'm getting red for no
reason she's bleeding from her head who
is the girl that stop moving I'm not
moving you're pinching my
arm I didn't do anything she was
fighting
everybody I'm going to go with you guys
and I'm getting arrested when girl is
okay I get all night like get them I'll
walk back I'm not leaving her with are
you sure you can take her no take her to
PD
and call my dad too okay are you okay
with that my dad's going to real
quick you should
drive yeah
okay pie you're piece of get off me
we're going get we're going now well
guess what now you
got grab my
again grab my
grab off my
[Applause]
ha chill out nobody's grabbing your
hair this could go a lot
[Music]
smoother
shut get
get ping
ass
[Applause]
no me
away no put on put a right now put
[Music]
on no Tony Tony we're just we'll just
come out we'll just come out your we'll
just come out your way I'm not pulling
but he's grabbing my
arm
really
please get off me you get off me get in
the car now get off me in the
car get the me get off me why is he
shoing me because you're freaking
kicking him that's why my
eyes kelse kelse sit
up sit up sit
up you all right yeah I'm good at bet
yeah
I want it she went for your best I don't
I don't even know if you saw her she
tried to bite I didn't I did that's why
I grabbed no we're doing egg bat for
kicking you enough
yeah grab my he's grabbing my
hair nobody's grabbing your hair chill
out Kelsey chill out nobody's grabbing
your hair relax this could go a lot
[Applause]
smoother
shut that's
[Music]
[Applause]
get Kelsey Kelsey here's here's the deal
we're we're going to get you out we're
going to walk you in in the jail okay
for what I'm asking I'm you're being
drunk he's drunk and driving here's what
I'm telling you going you're being
escorted into the jail and then we're
going to fight this going to
fight do that you can do that all you
want but what I'm doing is
asking I'm suggesting that you go with
the program this goes a lot smoother if
you go with the program you want me to
pull your shirt down for you
please there you
go we'll talk about this no
yeah you want to go around
yeah now listen this interruped okay you
have no idea I
geted can you your up please down or
down and my pants up please that's all
you want can youate a little bit I think
maybe you should make your off
CP he nothing
but the one that just
arrested
I right here okay I'm going to listen
you I swear I need you to pay attention
to her I will that's the only person you
need to listen to I will I just went to
jail for a domestic I know that's well
this isn't domestic Kelsey this is
battery swinging and hitting that girl
in the bar I never did anything she said
that she goes oh it wasn't her she even
said that I didn't do that well that's
what you're being charged with I
understand that but like she came on
near and I didn't do and then trying to
bite us and kick you KCK oh my my god
really when he's like grabbing me and
shoving me down he's trying to get you
in the car I was going I was going into
the car you don't understand that shut
let's add back oh whatever you want to
say I'm not trying to fight with anybody
you what are you gonna say whatever make
you see better you why
you knock can
I all right
so
battery um she tried to bite you yeah
and then she's
kicking she did she when well I know I
saw that yeah when me and Mark when I
got when you let me in there and I went
in cuz she wasn't she wasn't going out
with Mark I grabbed her by the arm she
went over and tried
to she tried to bite you didn't
bite okay so she tried to bite you got
stupid in there and then trying to get
her in the
car I'm
assuming what do you feel about
resisting baby we'll work that out she
ain't going you
baby
whatever yeah
yeah I love my
child make me like why are you so mad at
us we didn't we didn't bring you here no
I know I I just listen to her can you
please wipe my face out or my hair my
face
please please I don't want to I don't
want to fight I just don't want to
talking
about
Kelsey shut up you don't even give a you
care about yourself you're a strong I
care about my kid you don't give a you
care about your own like how you look
like in town you're a face my dad will
kill you get the out of here what else
are you on you do some coke tonight too
uh drug test me I can piss I'm so you
got sit down all I have is don't talk to
me don't
don't touch me don't touch me sit down
why is he touching me why is he touching
me just have a seat I can touch you and
but you beat your down real quick
they're out of there all right he needs
to not touch me he needs to not feel
stay seated nobody's going to touch you
okay well he needs to not feel
comfortable when he's doing drugs as
well just stay sitting around nobody's
going to touch you
I
my
please that was nice pretty good can I
like not have handcuffs on not at this
moment okay well for like no I'm sorry
what do you need I don't know if you
want me to wipe your tears or help you
blow your nose I can do that you like
call my mom not well call my mom on the
phone and call my dad right
now no I'm going to tell what's going on
cuz I'm not getting arrested for no damn
reason so you're going to see what's
happening calm my mind
M go
ahead call my head
am know what's going on with her
daughter okay listen this is why no no
I'm I no no no listen to me you don't
even know what listen to me in order to
get a phone call you would get a phone
call if you answer my questions you
understand and you could get your phone
call you could let people know you're
here all you have to do is answer my
question you understand then you get a
phone
call calm down answer my questions get a
phone call no I did nothing wrong yes I
did react maybe some way a different way
but ain't no man seem to grab me the way
you did so call call my mom and call my
dad and see what's going to happen we
can't call you and they're going to
react the way they're going to react
because they don't around okay well okay
so I'm getting in trouble for nothing
battery against the female and then you
have no it's not do you have do you have
the video yes we do we have the video
you okay show it and do you have the
video you me
n exactly exactly exactly and that's how
that's going to roll off it's pointless
to try lawyer
iny I guarantee yeah you will too guys
who's going to lose their job all
y'all well can you like get off don't
don't be p on her qu
grab hey hey're going to shoing she's
grabbing my arm we're going to walk to
the she's grabbing my arm get off me
grab my
arm Mak grab my you're making
thisen I need stop you w be understand
stop shut your
face I ain't doing
nothing
hold on to her hold on to her my
hand make him get off my hand you okay
okay will you make him get off my
hand my hand my hand
dude show me my hand my is
seriously
P seriously I'm not
[Music]
stop res if you kick me you're going to
get more
[Music]
sh I did nothing wrong put your arm
in let me call my dad get him off me on
me I call
911 no you're not you're
not I have toad I to to call your dad
you wouldn't do it I can't call you D
you have
to don't
call I have
to I'm
sure
[Applause]
me been tonight I don't care just stay
down you understand quit
[Applause]
resisting are you yeah